bien est-ce que vous m'entendez merci à
françois fillon de sa présence et de son
soutien nous allons parler maintenant de
la politique du logement
je vous demande un peu de concentration
parce que le logement c'est important
dans notre campagne avec valérie
pécresse est ce que vous êtes déterminés
à faire gagner valérie pécresse en faire
notre présidente de région
est ce que vous êtes déterminés à faire
de paris le premier département dans
cette région vainqueur le 13 décembre
alors je voudrais saluer nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui est la nôtre chef
de file à paris et qui mène un combat
courageux face à anne hidalgo tous les
jours et nous la soutenons aujourd'hui
demain dans ce combat difficile et nous
voulons gagner la région aussi pour
faire de la région ile-de-france en
contre-pouvoir à la politique de madame
hidalgo
alors le logement c'est un vrai sujet
lorsque philippe goujon a souhaité que
j'anime cette table ronde
je lui dit oui tout de suite le logement
parce que le logement c'est un peu comme
l'écologie pour la gauche on en parle
beaucoup depuis 17 ans la région ile de
france
on en parle beaucoup depuis plus de 14
ans la ville de paris et pourtant les
résultats sont médiocres
jamais en ile de france il n'y a eu
autant de familles en attente d'un
logement
écoutez bien ce chiffre plus de 500
mille familles j'ai pas dis personnes
familles sont en attente aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france d'un logement social c'est
un record absolu à paris intra muros
dans notre capitale plus de 180 mille
familles sont en attente d'un logement
social
le double depuis 14 ans à paris alors
ils nous disent qu'ils font du logement
et pourtant la crise n'a jamais été
aussi forte pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
dogmatiques le dogmatisme n'est pas une
solution
la politique qui a été menée consiste
simplement à préempter des logements
existants du logement privé il ya les
transformer en logements sociaux et une
fois que vous avez fait ça vous avez
dépensé beaucoup d'argent du
contribuable mais vous n'avez pas créé
un nouveau logement
ils ont re conventionnés les logements
des classes moyennes des logements
intermédiaires pour les transformer en
logements sociaux
ils n'ont pas créé un nouveau logement
ils ont changé une catégorie logement
par une autre pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
incorrigibles
ils veulent se faire une clientèle
électorale et je le vois dans le xviiie
arrondissement
on le voit dans beaucoup
d'arrondissement à paris cela a
construit des ghettos des ghettos où on
a repris les personnes sur leur plus
petit dénominateur commun et nous nous
voulons rompre avec valérie pécresse à
la région ile de france à paris avec ce
système là alors ils vont nous dire avec
michel thériault spécialiste des
questions du logement a délégué la fnai
m avec claude goasguen qui prendra le pr
la fnaim
le premier qui prendra la parole claude
goasguen le député maire du 16e qui a
pas peur d'aller au combat sur la
question du logement conseil de paris
valérie montandon conseillère de paris
du 12e spécialiste aussi éducation du
logement ainsi que jérôme dubus
conseiller de paris élu du xviie alors
nous allons travailler dans le projet de
valérie pécresse à la des ghettos
isation des quartiers en remettant les
classes moyennes au coeur des
préoccupations du logement nous voulons
réservé aux classes moyennes
une part du logement aidé nous ne
voulons plus finances et du logement
social
là où il y en a déjà plus de 30% mais là
où on pourra faire des programmes pour
les classes moyennes et notamment celles
et ceux qui vivent de leurs revenus du
travail car celles et ceux qui vivent de
leurs revenus du travail qui ont des
conditions de salaire modeste
aujourd'hui ne se voient proposer aucun
logement par la région ile de france ni
par la ville de paris quand on vit de
son revenu du travail
on a le droit d'accéder au logement et
de la même façon nous vous l'aura
relancer l'accession sociale à la
propriété
a paris il ya plus un programme
d'accession sociale à la propriété
parce que là aussi la gauche est
incorrigible elle considère que devenir
propriétaire lorsqu'on est de condition
modeste n'est pas un avenir
nous nous croyons que lorsque des hommes
et des femmes ont payé régulièrement
leurs loyers ont travaillé toute leur
vie ils ont droit devenir propriétaire à
la fin de leur vie et de transmettre un
bien à leurs enfants
c'est ça le mérite c'est ça l'ascenseur
social est ce que nous voulons relancer
avec valérie pécresse et ma conclusion
ce rapport notre nouvelle équipe de la
fédération en remercions très
chaleureusement fils goujon qui
m'accompagne chaque jour dans cette
campagne
avec détermination avec courage il est
un bon président de la fédération je le
remercie de son soutien
je voudrais féliciter la nouvelle équipe
avec frédéric péchenard et les nouveaux
secrétaires départementaux adjoints qui
vont insuffler une nouvelle énergie qui
va nous faire gagner la région ile de
france puis la france en 2010 est merci
beaucoup